I found my new favorite tick tocker oh
yeah and I wanted to review him with you
oh okay so this has just should just be
a country every week I'm gonna find a
tick tocker and it'll be my tick tocker
of the week my favorite Tick Tock of the
week that I want to share with you
that's really good yeah it's gonna be a
cool segment to do right
here's a 33 year old guy's favorite tick
tocker I'm 32. thank you very much 35
stop lying
it'll be 37 dude I think you're gonna
like this guy okay all right I'm
listening and watching okay wait look oh
this boy I've seen oh you've seen him
I've not seen anything he's done oh
let's go okay hold on I figured he would
I figured he'd be on your favorite Tick
Tock oh yeah oh yeah all right what's
going on beautiful day out here so I
just wanted to give everybody off of the
day so today we're wrapping American
Eagles one of my favorite Brands love to
wear it so got the American Eagle
t-shirt I have a bunch of their shirts
but this one's really new so I feel like
they go well with a lot of different
things
um got the American Eagle skinny jeans
personal favorite of mine love wearing
their jeans and then finishing out I got
the white Sperrys so pretty versatile
goes with a lot of different outfits and
of course I got the Maui Jim sunglasses
so yeah I feel like this is a pretty
clean outfit it looks good it's just is
regular person fashion
I love it it's not there's no discussion
about the materials the cut there's no
[__] fancy words it's just yeah this
is a brand I like
yeah
and like with all the confidence in the
world yeah he doesn't even consider what
other people think he's like I like this
brand yeah I think it goes with a lot of
different stuff yeah of course I got the
Maui Jims on yeah it's a pretty cleanup
see you later all right
all right and button down
that brown acid gray shoes is this is
one of my favorite outfits it's so old
money it looks great also got the 10K
followers yesterday this was awesome you
guys are great I really appreciate all
of you
I've never seen someone be like stand
so like unnaturally like yeah he has so
little sense of his body
yeah but he just doesn't care yeah
today's drink has been recommended for a
while now it's a brown sugar oat milk
shake and espresso oat milk milk no shot
man I love it man
and we're not even all the way through
but I love it because he's not trying to
flex on anybody no that's why this is so
endearing yeah
okay so I got my brown sugar oatmeal
damn what a cut what a cut let's get
that again
yeah that was crazy storytelling are we
going inside nope we are outside
facing away yeah we're going nowhere
you're actually gonna see not anything
to do with the inside it's really good
nice and simple Let's Dance that [__]
stance holy [__] yeah just a straight
arm really good
oh
it's the most confident unconfident
person yeah I love it that's chest day
so I'm about to bring you a Gym Fit
check I have a top from under armor with
Under Armor shorts and Adidas sauce for
your shoes but more importantly I just
want to say how important it is to go to
the gym there's so many benefits and
it's made this dude is a I feel like
it's a character it nah
this feels like NPC dialogue today's new
day to start fresh and start reaching
your goals
and he just walk by someone in the
street and they're like you should go to
the gym today
I just want to say you should go to the
gym every day rocket launcher
[Laughter]
I don't give a [__] what you think cars
straight into him
[Laughter]
I don't wish those things on this guy
it's horrible I don't wish these things
on that guy just I don't care what you
think the gym has made such a positive
impact on me oh
the thing I hate about the um NPC insult
yeah we call each other NPCs yeah is
that
like most people like someone will say
something on Tick Tock like wow NBC and
then you click their profile and it's
like
you know they are which is the most
normal person ever and it's like no one
really knows what this means yeah so I'm
not I don't think I'm saying that as an
insult or when we call him that it's not
an insult it's just he Nails the
everything yeah the same movements every
time the poses that it's like not like
video game it's like he's doing an NPC
character yeah NPC is funny because
we're all guilty of it what's
interesting is uh as as NPC as he may
come across he's going to do
exceptionally well in life yeah the
confidence and uh
the the height everything he's he's the
he's the real deal yeah this guy could
walk into a room and just like
so I was thinking like
I need like a million dollars for an
idea and everyone in the room will go
yes yes
it's him and as they're clapping he's
standing there like this
yes
as they're clapping they let the
colleagues look to each other and they
go my God he's in those American Eagle
jeans oh my God
pretty clean fit
wow very good sweet
um but a lot of the drinks I've been
trying are sweet and I like it that way
I love the foam on top I have to say
this would be a 9.3 out of 10. I'm a
white girl who knows her Starbucks 9.3
try it out you guys I promise you will
not be disappointed hey
shut up
[Laughter]
no
heck I think the thing I appreciate
about this appreciate about this the
most is
this is actually what any food review
should be of any major chain
because it's rammed full of sugar yeah
there's no way your brain will think
it's bad yeah that's a good point
anything from Starbucks yeah there's
nothing
deep you can say about it yeah this has
80 grams of sugar per bite it's good
yeah I like it a lot of the drinks have
been trying I've been this sweet can we
watch one or two more we can move on it
just I'm kind of obsessed with them yeah
no he's your favorite tick tocker of the
week of the week
it's a fun segment that I've started
doing another American Eagle outfit I
got the American Eagle tea with the
American Eagle skinny jeans
can't forget yeah
it's a little pump get a little pump
that's almost really dope and it's one
of the reasons American Eagles you can
build outfits like this that are simple
and affordable and look really good and
throw on the backwards hat if you really
want to have fun but yeah I'll be
rocking American Eagle all summer dude
the the response is great oh my God no
way my favorite brand
hahaha
[Laughter]
I love them who was holding his hat off
camera
this guy's like a magician yeah Carrie
and my lovely friend here she's just my
assistant would never be my girlfriend
I'm not into her
Carrie give me my hat
she's like yes Adam
it's also on backwards if you really
want to have fun hey she's from Maryland
I don't know people from Maryland
sounded like that others from Orange
County
or maybe he's not from Maryland maybe
he's just in Maryland for this outfit of
the day yeah anyways that's my favorite
tick tocker of the week shout out Adam
Jackie
nice man
what this is a good bit it's gonna be a
weekly segment yeah I know I know no
it's nothing there's nothing there's
nothing it's not a joke I know you know